nothing so the basis understanding of
American football there are two teams do
you have 11 players on either side there
are three phases of football you have
your offense you have your defense and
you have special teams but there's two
teams there's two teams each have three
phases
it's so during competition one team
Fields offense one team feels there's a
third team waiting behind The Stance
ready to Ambush no no the special ops
like special ops special teams special
teams do you could equate that to
special ops so your offense comes out on
the field you have five offensive
linemen five a quarterback a running
back a tight end tight end and then
you'll have three receivers three
receivers that's eleven you're good at
math thank you they can run the ball
which the quarterback will receive the
ball from the center yeah snap between
the legs okay could you just keep
snapping it forever could you make like
a chain of 11 people and they all snap
it between their legs all the way back
to the corner I mean you could but you
probably would lose or it's a trick
they're so confused the defense would
just tackle everyone no that's 11 in a
row you're gonna get through 11 people
no and strong you have 11 people on
defense yeah but there's a they're in a
row so they hide their numbers
what's stopping the football players
from stacking on each other's shoulders
Defenders oh someone tried that so yeah
there's technically a rule in the NFL
where you cannot utilize another player
to launch yourself but it would be sick
as hell though what about two people
heave hoeing someone that's again
launching but that's using two people it
doesn't matter it's still launching okay
all right what um generally speaking you
will see that kind of often snap they'll
snap the ball to the quarterback and the
quarterback can do one of two things is
he called the quarterback because there
are four of them no oh there's
technically a half back as well what is
that what that's that traditionally now
two quarterbacks on top of each other in
a trench coat with like a fedora on
their head it's like you morph two
together to merge into the half back and
then you morph two half backs to get a
full back and that's like a Shiny
Pokemon card you know super rare but
very valuable that's why they trade
players because it's like trading cards
right sure
all right I'm sorry I'm sorry continue
sorry continue so at the snap of the
ball quarterback get ball quarterback
throw ball ball catch defense tackle
quarterback get ball quarterback throw
ball defense catch ball turnover
turnover yes quarterback get ball
quarterback throw ball ball quarterback
pitch ball running back run forward
quarterback get lower back hand off ball
running back run to end so untouched so
let me just give a recap of everything
that I've learned so far it's from the
very beginning yeah there's a special
team like special ops they sneak up onto
the field under the darkness of night
all the people don't know because
they're camouflaged on the field they
have lines painted on ghillie suits that
look like the field and then they emerge
right and people don't know when the
game starts until they pop up out of the
ground and then they go and kick the
ball and then the other team who is
hiding in a secret formation out on the
receiving end they pop up and then they
catch the ball and they run it as far as
they can and then they switch out
there's an offense team and a little
defense team we don't know about the
defense team yet all right okay we've
talked about the offense let's talk
about the defense defense top offense
going to touchdown defense stop offense
from getting 10 yards in three defense
stop ball defense stop offense from
score points okay all right I'm gonna
give a summary of everything we've
learned so far so after the Special
Teams parachute into the stadium like
under the cover of Night Radio silence
underneath radar level they're dropped
in speed drop helicopter but a silent
helicopter no error nothing just
and it comes in and drops parachutes
they come down this is like midnight
next day game goes kick boom it's on
they pop up from the fields
guns are blazing across the field
bullets flying everywhere the other team
catches the ball they tackle them they
go down the offensive is trying to sack
that ball was it
don't tell me they're trying to S
between the legs Wham they snap they
snap the ball snap it right now they
crack it
boom to the quarterback he throws or
Chucks back or runs himself try to get
ball forward the defensive lineman they
don't take [ __ ] from nobody they've been
bullied their whole life they don't like
anybody no human animal nothing they're
full of hate nothing but hate they want
to stop that ball they're like
psychologically controlled from their
birth to hate balls
and they're just like No And so they do
whatever they can whatever dirty trick
knives whips chains I don't judge to
stop that ball from going forward and
that's football
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]